well as temperatures heat up in the
valley so will your energy bill as NV
Energy projecting what they call a huge
increase in July it doesn't stop there
though so for a lot of people they may
have to make some serious adjustments to
their monthly budget because of those
increases eight news now reporter
Victoria Saha explains what this could
mean the next time you have to pay your
energy bill
it's impossible to survive a summer in
the desert without cranking up your AC
and Marie citadino couldn't go any
longer without turning on her AC
a couple of freestanding fans to plus
the ceiling fans the kind of offset what
you would run
on the AC knowing the Envy energy rate
increase was looming she tried to hold
off it's really tough according to Envy
energy back in July of 2021 the average
customer was paying 260 dollars but now
they predict that number will go up to
at least four hundred dollars that's a
54 increase I'm worried about July
August and September because those are
our hottest months while we're with
citadino she took a glance at her energy
bill for June we're not nine percent and
the energy also proposing a 3.3 percent
increase by January for customers who've
been with them from 2020 to 2023. for
citadino who's on a fixed income the
increase leaves her making Cuts in the
kitchen you might hold off on
cooking more for someone who loves to
bake she's resorting to meals that don't
require electricity I put a mixture of
the goat cheese and the Gorgonzola
cheese it's another harsh reminder of
tough Economic Times Victoria Saha 8
News Now